[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment
of harry potter theory in this video
we're going to be discussing
dumbledore's loyal phoenix companion
fawkes fawkes is of course a phoenix
pottermore describes the phoenix as
follows
a phoenix is a bird with magical
properties large and coloured reddit and
gold
they can carry very heavy loads and
their tears have healing powers
on their burning days phoenix has burst
into flames and are reborn from the
ashes
forks is quite a prevalent character in
the harry potter series
and is often seen with hogwarts
headmaster albus dumbledore
the two were quite the pair and forks
had a great deal of loyalty to
dumbledore
the following excerpt from the chamber
of secrets is a testament to fork's
loyal companionship
professor dumbledore was standing by the
mantlepiece beaming
next to professor mcgonicle who was
taking great steadying gasps
clutching her chest fawkes went
whooshing past harry's ear
and settled on dumbledore's shoulder
just as harry found himself and ron
being swept into mrs weasley's tight
embrace many of the plot points in the
books and films come back to forks and
it is actually with the feathers of
forks that harry potter and tom riddle's
ones were produced
exactly said dumbledore harry's wand and
voldemort's wand
share cause each of them contains a
feather from the tail of the same
phoenix
this phoenix in fact he added and he
pointed at the scarlet and gold bird
perching peacefully on harry's knee my
once feather came from forks
harry said amazed yes said dumbledore
what this indicates is that it is likely
that dumbledore had known fawkes for at
least 60 years
in some ways the two were each other's
closest friends and for phoenix
which is generally an independent
creature to spend 60 years with the
wizard
speaks to the depth of their friendship
fawkes is quite an important character
and one of his most notable
accomplishments was when he saved
harry's life
on multiple occasions in the chamber of
secrets when harry was facing the
basilisk inside of the chamber
he was in real danger and one
frightening capability that the basilisk
has is the ability to turn people to
stone
by indirectly looking at them similar to
the old sailor's tale of medusa
or kill them by directly looking at them
when harry becomes aware of the
basilisk's capacity to kill with its
eyes alone
he's more disoriented than ever and
doesn't know how to face it
fortunately for harry fawkes
dumbledore's phoenix intervenes
and claws the basilisks eyes out this
blinds the basilisk
and means that it can no longer kill or
petrify with its menacing glare
at some point during harry's battle with
the basilisk he is bitten
when harry was bitten he yanked the fang
out of his arm
he knew that he had been wounded by the
venom and began to feel the poison
spreading
however fortunately for harry fawkes was
still nearby
when forks notices that harry is injured
he flies down next to harry
and cries on his arm the tears of a
phoenix are said to possess immense
healing capabilities
including but not limited to healing
wounds from those who have been
inflicted
with basilisks venom the tears are so
powerful that they can even revive
people who are at the brink of death
as harry was so when dumbledore is
killed and falls from the astronomy
tower
what happened to fawkes did he fly away
or does he simply continue to live on
the hogwarts grounds
a passage from the half blood prince
helps to give us an idea
gulping madame pomfrey pressed her
fingers to her mouth her eyes wide
somewhere out in the darkness a phoenix
was singing in a way harry had never
heard before
a stricken lament of terrible beauty and
harry felt
as he had felt about feeling song before
but the music was inside him
not without it was his own grief turned
magically to song
that echoed across the grounds and
through the castle windows
later on in the same book harry notices
that fork's singing stops
and assumes that fawkes has simply fled
the grounds to pursue independence
as he lay there he became aware suddenly
that the grounds were silent
fawkes had stopped singing and he knew
without knowing how he knew it
that the phoenix had gone had left
hogwarts for good
just as dumbledore had left to school
had left the world
had left harry further to this jk
rowling said the following in 2007
interview
something had to leave the school for
good when dumbledore died and i decided
that would be fawkes
dumbledore was a very great and
irreplaceable man and the loss of forks
and the fact that he was
non-transferable expresses this
symbolically and that's it for this
video what do you think
happened to fawkes let us know down in
the comment section below
until next time you're a wizard harry